okay we're gonna go through ten
questions that are gonna help you to
boost your SAT Math score so let's jump
into the first question which of the
following is equal to X to the 4/5 power
and we've got some multiple choice
options here so what do you think is at
E the fourth root of x to the fifth is
it'd be the square root of x to the
fifth is in C the fifth root of x to the
fourth or D is at the square root of x
to the 4/5 so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do this problem on
your own and of course we'll go through
it together
the thing that they're testing a sine
and this particular problem is that we
know our rational exponents basically
fractional exponents and the key here is
is that the denominator is the root or
the index and the numerator is the power
and the thing is they can put that power
here or they can put it on the outside
so they could say this is the fifth root
of x so the fourth like that either one
but if he can remember the numerator is
the power denominators the root you've
got it so it looks like it's going to be
this one right here letter C okay number
two see if you can do this one on your
own
it says the function G is defined by a
polynomial which of the following must
be a factor of G of X and they give us
some points here on the polynomial so
what do you think for this one is the
factor of G of X X minus 2 is that X
minus 6 is that X plus 1 or is an X
minus 1 so what they're really testing
us on here is the connection between
zeros and factors and when I talk about
what a zero is and what a factor is
let's just see if we can plot these
points just so I can demonstrate so
negative 1 4 is right there 0 2 is right
there 3 negative 1 is right here and 6 0
is right there so we have this you know
polynomial going through these points
polynomial is like a nice smooth curve
continuous right but when you talk about
the zeros what that means is that the
y-coordinate is a zero so see for
example here how this is up six commas
you're not going up or down that Y value
is zero that tells us that 6 is a zero
and that X minus six is a factor so you
want to remember that X minus whatever
the zero is is a factor so if it was a
negative number the X minus a negative
number those two negatives we cancel
give you a positive so it looks like for
this one letter B would you be your best
answer okay number three see if you can
pause the video and do this one on your
own it says given the line y equals MX
plus seven where M is a constant and
contains the point R comma T where R
does not equal 0 and T does not equal 0
what is the slope of the line in terms
of R and T ok so they're testing us on a
lot of different concepts in this
problem one is that you know your y
equals MX plus B form of the equation of
a line remember the slope intercept form
of the line and remember that B is the
y-intercept that M is the slope and when
you have a point that lies on the line
what that means is that if you were to
plug in those x and y-coordinates it's
going to make the equation true so let's
go ahead and do that so here you can see
T is our Y value so we have T equals M
times R which is our x value plus 7 now
the other thing they're testing a sign
is this language that you want to be
familiar with in terms of what is in
terms of mean well we want to get the
slope which is our M value in terms of R
and T meaning we want to get the M by
itself we want to get everything else on
the other side of the equation only
containing R's T's and constants in this
case seven is a constant so how do we
get this M by itself when we think about
working from the outside in so I would
subtract seven from both sides of the
equation to keep it balanced right and
then we want to get M by itself so
what's the opposite of multiplying by R
divided by R and now you can see that M
equals T minus 7 divided by R which
looks like letter D and you got it okay
number four see if you can do this one
on your own 2x minus a y equals 12 6x
minus 9 y equals 36 in the system of
equations above a is a constant and x
and y are variables for what value of a
will the system have it
Solutions and we've got what a B 3 you
would a B 4 with a B negative 3 or would
a be nine what do you think see if you
can pause the video and do this one the
thing that they're testing us on here
are basically systems of equations with
lines and we're trying to figure out do
they cross that like one point are they
parallel do they cross that no points or
are they the exact same line meaning
that they're crossing at an infinite
number of points well if they have
different slopes meaning they're going
up at different angles they're gonna
cross at one point if they have the same
slope but a different y-intercept then
they're gonna be parallel they're just
not going to be no solution but again if
they're the same line they have the same
slope and the same y intercept then
there's going to be an infinite number
of solutions now again like I said if
they're infinite number of solutions
that means that they're the same line
right so when you look at these
equations here you can always multiply
an equation by a constant it'll be the
same line as long as you do it to
everything in the equation left and
right sides you keep it balanced right
so what I notice here is that if I
multiply this top equation by 3 you know
and I distribute that 3 to everything in
the equation here that's gonna give us
6x minus 3a y equals 36 so let's just go
ahead and write that down so I'll put it
right underneath here 6x minus 3a y
equals 36 so you can see that these
equations are gonna be exactly the same
as long as this negative 3/8 is equal to
this negative 9 right so all we have to
do is make a simple equation here
negative 3a is equal to negative 9
divide both sides by negative 3 and you
can see that a is equal to positive
three which is letter A and you got it
okay number five see if you can do this
one on your own y equals K times X minus
three times X minus seven in the
equation above K is a nonzero constant
the graph of the equation in the XY
plane is a parabola with vertex L comma
M which of the following is eat
to em okay that's an interesting
question so when they tell us it's a
parabola we know it has this kind of you
type shape we're looking for that vertex
that point where the graph of bands and
that's our vertex right there at L comma
M now what they're testing us on in this
problem is that we know our different
forms of the equation of a parabola and
let me just write down those forms here
for you it's going to be y equals R like
our general form ax squared plus BX plus
C there's our vertex form which is a
times the quantity X minus H squared
plus K and then there's what's called
our intercept form I'll just call this a
times X minus px minus Q it's like a fad
form now you can see that they're giving
it to us in this third form here this
intercept form and what that means is
that if we were to set these factors
these groups equal to 0 we can find the
x-intercepts so by setting X minus 3
equal to 0 you can see that we get x
equals 3 and if we set X minus 7 equal
to 0 you can see that we get x equals 7
so let's just draw like a kind of a
rough sketch here we know that the graph
is gonna cross you're at 3 4 5 6 & 7 so
the graph might be opening up it might
be opening down but one thing you'll
notice about these parabolas is that
they have an axis of symmetry meaning if
you fold it over that line that goes
through the vertex is going to match up
with itself right so we all we have to
do is find this halfway point which is
going to be right here at 5 another way
of finding the halfway point is to add
these two numbers together 3 plus 7 is
10 and divided by 2 that's also 5 so we
know that the axis of symmetry is x
equals 5 it's also going to be the
x-coordinate of the vertex so we know
that L at 5 is the x-coordinate the
vertex so if we put 5 in for X right
let's go ahead and do that we have y
equals K times 5 minus 3 which is 2 5
minus 7 which is negative 2 now we can
simplify a little bit down further this
is a negative for K and we know that our
y coordinate of our vertex is is M right
and it's
which of the following is equal to em so
I'm just going to put em here this
instances are our y coordinate of our
vertex and we want to solve for M so
which one is equal to M that's going to
be negative for K which you can see here
is letter C and you got it so if you're
enjoying this video so far and you want
to learn more about how to really do
well on that math section of the SAT
check out my huge SAT math review video
course where I go through 39 important
concepts that you're going to want to
know to really do well on the math
portion of SAT so check it out and we'll
continue on with this video we've got
four more questions so let's go to
number six okay number six see if you
can do this one on your own
given the formula for the volume of a
sphere which is V equals 4/3 PI R cubed
which of the following gives R in terms
of V so we saw this language earlier in
this video in a different problem but
here we're specifically just focusing on
rewriting this formula such that you're
getting R in terms of V so is it a B C
or D see if you can do this one on your
own if I was gonna do it what I would do
is I would think about working from the
outside in towards that our okay so in
order to get rid of this 4/3 okay I
would multiply both sides of the
equation by 3/4 now you can think of V
as like V over 1 because anything
divided by 1 is itself and so you can
now you have 3v over 4 equals PI R cubed
we're still working from the outside in
towards that our how do we get rid of
the PI well instead of Multan by PI we
can divide by PI or you can think about
multiplying by the reciprocal so I'm
gonna multiply both sides by 1 over pi
the PI's cancel now we have our cubed
equals 3v over 4 pi we want to get rid
of the cube the opposite of the cubing
something is to take the cube root so if
I take the cube root of both sides now
you can see that R equals this quantity
here which looks like letter D and you
got it okay number seven see if you can
do this one on your own
it says the surface area of a human's
lungs is equal to
half of a tennis court which is about
2,100 square feet how many square feet
would the lungs of a 30-person baseball
team cover okay kind of a bizarre story
problem but what they're testing us on
here is proportions okay and so what you
want to do here is you want to basically
realize that half of a tennis court
would be about a thousand and fifty feet
squared so that's per one adults lungs
so I'll say one pair of lungs okay but
we want to find out what the area would
be for a 30-person baseball team so
we're now we're talking about 30 pairs
of lungs okay and so now all we have to
do is when you do proportion we make
sure you've got like the area to the
number of lungs area to the number of
lungs you don't want to switch those
around you want to keep them in the same
order so if it's like square feet per
long square feet per Long's then only
have to do is cross multiply on the
diagonal to solve this proportion so you
can see 8 times 1 is a 30 times a
thousand 50 is 30 1500 and that's gonna
be the best answer for this one so
proportions is an important concept to
know I'm SAT okay number eight see if
you can do this one if two minus 3i
divided by 4 plus 5i is rewritten in a
plus bi form what is the value of B is
it 22 ninths is it 9 20 seconds is it
negative 22 over 41 or is it 7 over 41
so what do you think for that one well
the key here with this problem is you
want to get rid of the I in the
denominator that's considered you know
improper and because this is a binomial
see two terms what you want to do is you
want to multiply by the complex
conjugate so what you do is you change
the sign to the opposite so this is
minus this would be plus of course
whatever you multiply the denominator by
you want to multiply the numerator by
because that's like multiplying by one
since these would cancel out so now what
we have to do is we just have to
multiply the numerators together
multiply the denominators together and
we have a binomial times a binomial we
can foil or distribute twice so let's go
ahead and do that so we've got 2 times 4
which is 8
two times negative five I is negative
ten I okay if we distribute the negative
3i now we get negative 12i and plus 15i
squared okay all divided by 4 times 4
which is 16 4 times negative 5 is
negative 20 I 5 I times 4 is positive 20
I notice those cancel and 5 I times
negative 5 is negative 25 I squared now
remember what is I equal it represents
the square root of negative 1 what is I
squared equal it's negative 1 so a
couple things you might want to memorize
here if you don't know already but you
can see if we put in a negative 1 for I
squared here a negative 1 times negative
25 is positive 25 plus the 16 gives us
41 and over here I squared is negative 1
times 15 is negative 15 plus 8 is
negative 7 minus 22 I I'm just combining
those treating them like like terms so
now what you can do is you can divide
this by 41 this by 41 so I'm just
splitting it up into two fractions okay
so we have the real part a and the
imaginary part the BI part separated so
it's in the standard a plus bi form now
it wants to know what is B and you can
see B is this part here in front of the
I that's negative 22 over 41 so letter C
would be your best answer for that one
okay number 9 see if you can do this one
so it says which of the following is an
equivalent form of the equation of the
graph for which the coordinates of the
vertex point B can be identified as
constants in the equation so constants
are just like numbers not variables so
we talked about this in another question
in this video and it's really testing
you on you know do you know your forms
of your quadratic or your parabola
you've Gallacher general form that's
this one here we've got our vertex form
that's the second one and we have our
intercept form that's this third one
here and so which one do you think it is
is it a B C or D well you can see that
letter D and letter C these are like in
the general form so that rules those out
letter B is in the intercept form
meaning if you set these factors
is equal to zero you're gonna get the
x-intercepts like zero and negative for
that rules that one oh that's focused on
the intercepts it has to be letter a
this is our vertex negative 2 negative 4
so we're going left to down 4 remember
the number that's grouped with the ax
has the opposite effect so a plus 2 is
actually shifting left 2 this has the
same effect down 4 so as far as focusing
on the vertex in terms of the constants
in the equation that would be letter A
would be your best answer okay number 10
see if you can do this problem on your
own
it says the equation C equals 10 H plus
20 is used to find the cost C of renting
a boat for each hours what does the 20
represent in the equation is it letter a
how much it costs to rent the boat for
one hour or is it be the total cost of
running the boat or is it C the starting
cost to rent the boat or is it D how
many boats are available to rent so what
do you think for that one well what
they're testing us on in this equation
and it's alright in this problem here is
the y equals MX plus B form of the
equation of a line and remember that the
M is the slope the B is the y-intercept
but in a story problem or a word problem
the slope you can think of that as the
rate and the B this is like the initial
condition or the starting amount so in
this particular problem the 20 would
represent the starting amount the 10
would represent the rate meaning like
the cost per hour and you can test this
out if you put one in for each one hour
then you can see the price is going to
be 30 if you put 0 hours it's going to
be 20 so you can see it's going up by 10
dollars every hour C of course
represents the total cost depending
after however many hours that you rent
the boat for so it looks like the best
answer here is going to be a letter C
which is the starting cost to rent the
boat and you got it so if you're
enjoying this video and you want more
SAT math practice of course check out my
course for sale but you can also take a
look at the videos I did over there and
that playlist going over some additional
SAT practice I'll see you over in those
videos I'll talk to you that